und im heutigen seminar in der letzten
sitzung unseres semesters wollen wir uns
mit dieser interessanten personen hannah
arendt auseinandersetzen
und ich denke besonders gut geeignet
dafür um uns ihren anzunehmen ist neben
diesem referat noch ein filmausschnitt
und dem möchte ich ihnen kurz vor
spielen und bei filmen ist es ja immer
so filme als solche bringen ja nichts
wenn man sie nur sich anschaut sondern
filme sollte man immer das habe ich bei
herrn schütz gelernt immer unter einem
bestimmten focus sich anschauen
ein film spricht nur selten für sich
spricht sicherlich für sich aber im
wissenschaftlichen hinsichten ist es
besser den film unter bestimmten
fragestellungen zu lesen und ich habe
jetzt hier mal so zwei fragen hin
geschrieben also eine frage wäre
worin besteht die banalität des bösen
nach einer art seine wendung und dann
inwiefern ist diese wendung
problematisch oder missverständlich und
das werden wir jetzt gleich sehen in
diesem video ausschnitt sie sagen mir
bitte ob es laut genug ist
das foto der jubilar
wenn die new yorker cent der report on
the trial of adolf eichmann als und
seine forderung hat oliver interesse
demands of justice des wassers des
altars wie koste kurz erdreich monrose
confronted wie sieg ein
ich konnte noch feind insel lombok die
criminals like the sun hätte faymann s
men und trial for his team's
systemtreuer neue story personalleiter
eichmann was sagt die erste tonne
razingar personal qualität des service
nummer die left to be japanischer
vergeben
die proteste beim entgelt kontrollierte
prostitution surgeon said he had never
gonna sing out that i had no angels for
that he had only way back on a chip lake
city setzte gerätes ihn sofort ist sie
über committed bei nobel komitee am ende
auf mode bis auf conviction swiss aus
wickede monik wild things are used to
persons in that i have corp
drei reporter net unterhalte klare
freise roll up soll sleegers rupert
aspekte directly in eichmanns activities
jubel vor der rauen destruction eine
problems
das ist es was etwas über tabs der as
something inbetween resistance and
cooperation and only and say that may be
closely das meinte hälfte francisco vom
import du hast ist bestens because the
role of jewish leaders gibt es streit im
insight into that talk wie auf dem
mohrenplatz setzte nazis in respektabler
abgeben zu sein
and not only in the bei den orders all
countries man sie per secure web for the
victims
eichmanns fans dieses crimes against
humanity human resources sony streitet
betreiben der ganze mist bei der
finnischen against humanity juno in der
binder takt verbiegen ist auf rating
modefans nazis ins korn zur oper jazz is
not
dann ist der charakter sassenroth die
fans auf eichmann partei die drei tore
gonzalo schott in new york city auch zum
endboss ist eher gering die 200 and is
not the same as vergiss es jedesmal
response ability to understand the
responsibility of anyone who die ersten
sechs sind sokratis an play to be used
for taking to be engaged in the silent
dialogue between and myself in reviews
intubiert person eichmann attali
verändert single muss der feinen human
quality of being able to his inability
to sink kreativkonzept question
philosoph michael bay
die manifestation of the wind offshore
ist knowledge
mobility health beauty food service
peter strucks lopavent katastrophe cindy
shermans wenn sie chips order senken
[Applaus]
so also ein interessanter ausschnitt
dieses filmes glaube er ist so fünf
jahre alt 45 jahre alt und sie sehen
dieser vortrag von hannah arendt hat im
publikum gemischt emotionen reaktion
ausgelöst wenn sie mal auf das ende
dieser vorlesung nur noch mal schauen
sehen sie ein herr mit den schwarzen
haaren der ist empört aufgestanden und
hat als erster versuch diese
veranstaltung zu verlassen andere
blieben sitzen und haben ganz begeistert
applaudiert und jetzt wird die frage an
sie auch bezogen auf diese zwei fragen
was war los warum hat hannah arendt
theorie wurde ihre auffassung muss man
sagen dieser sachlage um eichmann also
wir sind ja alle was es mit eigentlich
mal auf sich hat also es geht
letztendlich darum um die transporte von
jüdischen mitbürgern eben in diese
konzentrationslagern eichmann war daran
beteiligt auf eine gewisse weise und die
frage ist eben die welche rolle kommt
ihm jetzt dabei zu und sie hatte hier
einige beschreibungen gebracht weil man
vielleicht erinnern sie sich noch an
diese wenden weil sie mit von ihnen noch
was sie hier gesagt hat über eichmann
dass wir vielleicht auch noch eine
mögliche fragestellung gewesen die sich
hätten überlegen können wollen sie
gerade dazu zu dieser frage was war ich
mal gesagt hat ja
wir sehen
er verspricht und auch gar nicht
irgendwie wird man sagt die fähigkeit so
abgrundtief böse zu sein wie das was
getan hat nicht in der man sieht einfach
nur wie die person die orgel im
vorlesungssaal setzen können genau das
war ein punkt ja
dagegen unsere ordner verschickt und
diesmal hört und dadurch einen baum
draußen oder ist eine banale personen
eine person werde nicht orientieren
personen seien aus dass gefährliche
lösung ist und ich glaube dieser
beziehung fehler machen dass dann viele
sehr banal gewesen also nicht wir haben
die folgen zu denken
der vorsprung des
das geht aus unserem gerne halten
gut also ich glaube so ein problem hier
ist eben dass viele dann gemeint hatten
eine art würde das böse selbst
banalisieren sie haben gut unterschieden
zwischen den motiven oder dem grund und
den folgen und wenn man natürlich die
folgen sieht könnte man natürlich nicht
ohne zynisch zu sein sagen dass sie
banal waren als es bezieht sich eher auf
den protagonisten auf das objekt ja sie
noch das ist nicht mehr das in die bio
selbst zu verantwortenden geld
guter punkt also wir haben jetzt hier
wichtige themen bereits angesprochen es
geht um die frage nach der bedeutung
nach der gestaltet größen angesichts
moderner gesellschaften bzw totalitärer
gesellschaften totalitärer systeme in
denen es möglich ist
befehle es so auszuüben dass man am ende
gar nicht mehr unbedingt sieht wohin das
führt stichwort schreibtischtäter ist so
ein eines dieser wörter die da immer
wieder auftaucht
ja ist eine gute wendung denke ich wir
diskutieren jetzt leicht drüber also
dass jetzt nur zu diesen eindrücken sie
haben gesehen also das publikum und ich
glaube das trifft sehr gut wie es auch
zu ihrer zeit war das war polarisiert
das war gespalten und wir haben heute in
diesem sehr informativen referat gehört
das hannah arendt sogar sanktioniert
wurde da sie zu einer nord persona non
grata erklärt wurde
also ihre aussagen sind durchaus
kontrovers aufgenommen worden
dazu muss man vielleicht auch sagen dass
hannah arendt immer sehr provokativ auch
formuliert hat das haben wir auch jetzt
am referat gesehen und ihre
persönlichkeit sehr früh reif sehr
willens stark in ihren entscheidungen
sich sonderrechte aus bedingen dass sie
morgens nicht so früh die schule musste
oder da eine affäre mit einem studenten
als ich weiß nich vier alte schülerin
oder dann mit mit mit martin heidegger
also sie ist eine sehr charakter starke
persönlichkeit gewesen die durchaus
gerne starke provokative thesen
formuliert hat und wir wollen jetzt
heute in diesem in dieser sitzung
untersuchen inwiefern mit diesen
durchaus problematischen oder
provokativen äußerungen wendungen einen
sinn abgewinnen können der die frage
betrifft wie die welche form des
unmoralischen oder bösen wir eben in
totalitären system oder in der moderne
grundsätzlich entdecken können das ist
hier jetzt nochmal dieses plakat dieses
filmplakat
ich glaube dass die barbara sukowa hat
das ist die halt die darstellerin der
kanaren im hintergrund sehen sie weiß
jemand wie dieses gebäude hier heißt
hier
ich dachte erst ich wüsste es aber dann
habe ich mich selbst noch korrigieren
müssen ja
ja richtig ja also nicht dass ein paar
state building ist empire state building
ist noch ein bisschen zackiger das geht
hier so zackig runter und das ist hier
schon mit rundbögen ja ich weiß leider
building und sie wissen alle
hannah arendt haben auch im referat
gehört ist dann in die usa gegangen hat
an der new school for social research
hat sie dann gelehrt und da ist heute
immer noch wenn sie in diesen news cool
mal reingehen dieses gebäude dann sehen
sie denn ich weiß nicht wievielten stock
eine tafel in der wand eingelassen wo
alle die namen verzeichnet sind
derjenigen dozenten dort die eben
fliehen mussten aus deutschland oder aus
europa dann dort geben als
universitätsdozenten gewirkt haben dass
eine ganze liste ich hab so also
fotografiert ich kann es auch mal ins
video stellen ich werde es dann
wahrscheinlich auch noch hier in diesem
der aufzeichnung dieses seminars auch
noch einblenden dass man mal die ganzen
namen sieht das sind als unglaublich
viele bedeutende denker hat die da dann
in new york untergekommen sind an dieser
new school die auch heute noch ein sehr
profilierte universität ist gerade wenn
es um sozialphilosophie geht politische
philosophie da ist die new school immer
noch sehr gut
ja dann würde ich sagen gehen wir mal so
ein bisschen auf diese leitfragen
überall so wir lesen uns ein paar zitate
aus ihren schriften über das böse
vorlesung über das böse
vor allem und da haben uns ein paar
fragen also welchen zugang wählten zum
problem des bösen wie verhält sich ihre
theorie zur philosophischen tradition
des begriffs des bösen wir haben im
referat gehört das hannah arendt sich
sehr gut auskannte mit der
philosophischen traditionen wir haben
gehört sie hat ihre dissertation bei
karl jaspers über den liebes begriff bei
augustinus geschrieben augustinus den
haben wir hier auch in diesem seminar
behandelt
in hannah arendt hat auch noch ein
weiteres buch geschrieben vom leben des
geistes und darin ist sie auf den
begriff des willens oder des wollens
eingegangen und hat auch da sehr viel
über augustinus geschrieben und sie hat
augoustinos einmal als den erfinder oder
entdecker des modernen willens begriffs
bezeichnet wir hatten ja auch gelesen
dieser schrift der libero abi trio und
gesehen dass er da durchaus
differenziert
angebracht hat also sie hat eine starke
kenntnis eine gute kenntnis der antike
sie kennt sich aus mit platon mit
sokrates das ist die frage dann haben
wir hier eine passage in diesen texten
wo sie sich kritisch mit kranz theorie
des bösen auseinander setzt und dann
wollen wir uns abschließen mit der frage
befassen wie sich hanna ahrens theorie
ist die frage ist es eine theorie des
bösen ansicht des bösen vorschlag des
bösen wie sich das bewerten lässt
inwiefern es systematisch überzeugend
ist diese theorie ohne wiefern darin
probleme liegen oder ob irgendwelche
formulierung vielleicht besser anders
hätten formuliert werden müssen
diese fragen wollen wir am ende noch
aufwerfen und jetzt gehen wir doch mal
mitten im text rein ich habe ein paar
zitate ausgewählt die ich besonders
prägnant finde wenn sie aber selbst noch
andere zitate haben die sie gerne auch
hier diskutiert wissen wollen dann
melden sie sich dieser text hier ist
jetzt aus der vorlesung über das böse
öbb habe ich jetzt abgekürzt ich jetzt
mal vor wir könnten ein bisschen besser
dran sein wenn wir uns erlaubten die
literatur heranzuziehen also shakespeare
malware oder dostojewski bei denen wir
die großen schurken finden auch sie
mögen nicht in der lage sein uns genauso
über das wesen des bösen zu erzählen
aber wenigstens weichen sie ihm nicht
aus wir wissen ja können fasst sehen wie
es sie dauernd verfolgt hat und wie gut
sie über die möglichkeiten der
menschlichen schlechtigkeit bescheid
wusste und doch frage ich mich ob uns
das sehr viel weiterhelfen würde
beim größten schurken gago nicht macbeth
oder richard der dritte klettert in
mcqueens beliefert und überall bei
dostojewski gibt es in den tiefen immer
verzweiflung und den neid der zur
verzweiflung gehört das alles radikal
böse aus den tiefen der verzweiflung
kommt hat uns ausdrücklich hier gegangen
er sagt den wir vor zwei sitzungen
behandelt
es klingt so sehr überzeugend plausibel
war uns auch gesagt und beigebracht
wurde dass der teufel nicht nur diabolos
ist nicht nur versäumt hat der falsch
zeugnis reden oder satan der gegner der
den menschen in versuchung führt sondern
dass er auch ein luzifer ist
lichtbringer ein gefallener engel also
jetzt ergeben sich in diesem zitat sehr
viele interessante bezüge zum einen eben
zur kirche goals theorie der
verzweiflung und dann wie mir scheint
auch noch so ein bisschen jetzt nicht
direkt von die intensität aber paul
tillich unterscheidung zwischen dem
satan und dem teufel und dem dämonischen
das könnte man hier eventuell auch noch
etwas an bringen was ist jetzt ihre
intention warum geht sie jetzt hier auf
die literatur ein wenn es darum geht
eichmann zu beschreiben warum rekurriert
sie jetzt hier auf die literatur und was
sagt sie ist bei diesen literarischen
bösewichten der fall
er stellt
zusammenfassend festgestellt also das
was man bisher als bösen allgemein sieht
darin die liste wird dargestellt wird
woran ist ein wenige name desto besser
das böse motiviert in die offensive
da sagt dem team der 2 das böse sind
also nicht unbedingt sind das ist schon
ziemlich oft auch der einfache aber
unbedingt was das positive denken dass
irgendwas ja richtig also man kann diese
persönlichkeiten kann man schon fast
sagen die kann man dingfest machen die
haben motive die haben einen grund des
bösen die verzweiflung und hier sagt sie
in dieser zeile hier der fünften zeile
aber wenigstens weichen sie diese
genannten personen im dem bösen nicht
aus
und das ist eben das was die man das
böse eben bisher gesehen hat das system
anders aufgetreten das böse war das
ausscheiden ich liebe es ist natürlich
auch wenn sie sich sowohl mit gründen
motive einer person oder einem charakter
einen charakter vielleicht auch genau
ich glaube dass das jetzt und bis in der
hintergrund ist von ahrens betrachtung
von eichmann also die hintergrund folie
sind schurken klassische bösewichte aus
der weltliteratur und damit vergleicht
sie jetzt aber sie hatten sich noch
gemüse
also dass man eben dem bösen ausweichen
möchte auch in der theorie na so was
meinen sie ok haben sie sonst noch hier
bezüge gefunden
kirchenchor verzweiflung dostojewski an
wen denken sie bei dostojewski
bergretter anfrage dostojewski wenn es
um das böse geht ja es gibt verschiedene
also ich meine es gibt nicht nur ein
werk das wäre eine möglichkeit ja oder
denken sie mal an schuld und sühne
verbrechen und strafe nach der
moderneren übersetzung das kolleg oft
lisa protagonist der ja auch schon was
böses tut indem man die pfandleiher in
ermordet natürlich aus gewissen gründen
heraus legt sich so zu recht als ob der
mord am ende gerechtfertigt wäre
es gibt bei brustkrebs gehen wir sehr
starke charaktere die sich die nicht dem
bösen ausweichen also anhand deren man
nicht den bösen ausweichen kann so
müsste man es vielleicht zahlen
die es eben nicht erlauben den bösen zu
entweichen theoretischen hier ist noch
ein wichtiger anderer bezog kennen sie
von herman melville diese kurzgeschichte
billy budd haben sie die mal gelesen
hier kennen sie die wir von ihnen hat es
mal gelesen einfach mal melden
ja es lohnt sich wirklich eine ganz ganz
tolle geschichte peter sag mal was dazu
was war deine deinen lese eindruck wenn
du dich noch erinnern ist an billy budd
ist eine kurzgeschichte oder naja nicht
ganz
sein 50 ja aber ist es nicht so lange
opulente roman wie mobile gewonnen und
ist eine anekdote ein
ereignisse auf see auf einem schiff wo
ein
eigentlich gibt eine lichtgestalt die
steckt steht im mittelpunkt der
erzählung kann man sagen dass wir die
bahn relevant ist ein leichtmatrose also
ein österreicher ganz ganz oben
anzusiedeln ist aber eine lichtgestalt
und dann immer dass er äußerlich ist das
gut aussieht aber nicht oberflächlich
erotischen sinne sondern einfach eine
erscheinung ist die jeder positiv und
dann ist er aber auch in seinem handwerk
und in den wasserturm landeck ist er
immer der beste aber nicht so dass er
der durchstartet ist an dem sich dann
alle konkurrenz mäßig raidl immer
freundlich ohne schlimmeres zu sehen ist
einfach schlichtweg der der in jeder
hinsicht restlos positiv ist naiv auch
wieder gewissen sich da ich glaube ich
auch geld
so ein reaktor also eine kirchliches ein
tägliches gemüt eine kindlich rey nicht
nur die überhaupt nichts negatives
problematisches an sich hat die auch bei
der menschen so etwas wie neid und so
eigentlich nicht erzeugt die jeder liebt
und jeder genau und zwar durch allen
bereichen hindurch mann der es fast so
eine art ja alles machen dieses schiff
und dann gibt es jetzt bei einem board
aus hält es ist sehr direkt und
assistent ärgert es wird wirklich der
inbegriff des japanischen vom
äußerlichen hinterhältigen und
fragwürdige figur die ihn anfang zu
drangsalieren und dann immer bilder
immer
ja immer dramatischer spitz ist das zu
denn seinen scheitern zu sein sondern
steigert diesen hass noch also also dass
es billiger ist ewigen über nämlich
nicht wir werden das nicht ab oder so
sondern hat dann immer noch versteht ist
oder missverstehen dieses negative unser
baut sich dieses böse in diesem claire
geld könnte man sagen immer weiter auf
und am ende kommt es dann zu einem
vorfall
es geht wohl um es geht um den ball
es ist so dass klettert dann dem billy
budd unterstellt dass er an einer
meuterei beteiligt gewesen seien
sie wissen ja auf dem schiff ist
meuterei wird mit dem tod bestraft und
so kommt dann auch er wird gehängt
meines wissens in der takelage also
dass solche vergehen angehängten mit
lagert und dann kommt es zu einer höhe
von zweifeln und zuhörer an bord und dem
kapitän mit allen offizieren und vor den
augen dieser offiziere die alle uni was
natürlich positiv sehen und wissen und
kleckert einen eigenen scharlatan ist
also schon arm ist diese vorwürfe nicht
wirklich recht hat ist dann spricht man
dieses verfahren schon zu viel gießen
vorteil ausgehen wie roll kleinert
nochmal vornehmen
seine vorwürfe und hängt also beliefert
wieder das wichtigste widerwärtigsten
mannschaft motive werden
richtig wiederum kann das bricht für ihn
eine welt zusammen ist ein mensch
überhaupt in der lage die ausfuhren
wieder solche für jeden einen
unschuldigen entspannt
doch sehr
und er stirbt glaube ich dabei das
ergebnis ist die bahn vor den augen
allem offiziere das heißt es gab es auch
noch einige teure gab es nichts zu
beschönigen
jetzt wissen sie natürlich alle diese
ist eigentlich unschuldig und es war
auch kein nordmann wo leute sagen
totschlag und so weiter aber sie müssen
beraten lassen dass das was kann denn es
gibt da einen verfahren die stimmen
aller und das ist ergebnis ist
tatsächlich alleinschuldigen dieser
meuterei zu verhindern so weiter müssen
sie dieses urteil gefällt und sie fällt
das urteil muss hängt gegen ihre eigenen
und gegen den willen der ganz zu
abschaffen und dieses muss am ende
tatsächlich versteckt also gemeldet
unser ziel ist in der reihe geschichte
einer mit riskanten das englisch über
beschreibt es dann wie der körper dann
mit der sonne zugewandten die ganze wahl
hängt und zu schweben scheint das ist
eine schlüsselszene der volg dem hängen
noch sagen lang lebe captain noch was im
feld und der natürlich auch bei der
mannschaft ist
leichter hat und dabei die stärke für
den frieden und für die weiterfahrt
weil es in diesem ideologischen zu sehen
haben ende unglaublich rührung und stark
gemacht also
ja ist eine kurze geschichte genau als
es lohnt sich vielen dank peter also es
lohnt sich welches zu lesen es ist ein
klassiker der weltliteratur
hier ist eben ein typus trend erklärt
der eben wie man jetzt sagen können dem
anknüpfen und das was du bereits wieder
gegeben hat ist den das reine gute
provoziert der stößt sich nicht daran
dass der jetzt einfach besser ist und
mit ihm eine konkurrenz tritt sollen den
provoziert dass der so naiv gut ist also
das gute als solches empört haben wir
auch schon ein bisschen bei augustinus
also dieser tendenz des gebots
übertrieben des gebotes wegen will kommt
mit tiefendimension des bösen spiel und
vor diesem hintergrund vor diesem profil
klägers betrachtet jetzt hannah arendt
die person reichen land das müssen sie
sich einfach als kontrast immer
vergegenwärtigen
ist dann jetzt der master noch aus
verzweifelung selber diese weise heute
mit dass er in einem stehen weil er es
nicht die gewalt oder die aktion steigt
und der beginn einen taten zu und nicht
moralisch in ordnung ist wie menden
steht das würde einem körperzonen ob er
dazu geht es wie kann man das dann jetzt
sehen er kann so eine stabile 27
das ist ja so oder so dass das einen
bösen tat im affekt von effekten
wird überhaupt nicht also auch viele
jetzt auf einmal auch zum geschaltet
wird
oder nicht das wird überhaupt nicht
gesagt hinter dem primus denke ich kann
man klar war dass man die sympathien
waren neben formieren
also das ist mir sehr schlecht heißt
sondern gegenteil aber verstehen
dieser hass ist identisch sogar der das
zeigt das ist der kläger bisher seien
problemlos für alle und durch diese
aktion wird das schiff von diesem gleich
beschreibt man könnte es also super fast
schon fest ein paar kleiner prinz in
lausanne kläger ist er notwendig um die
viele hersteller auf sicht und stirbt
auch für das ökologische szene
anstatt nur die bösen trifft religiöse
infizierte
und da sind solche fragen haben
ganz billig ist es nicht auch so dass
jesus ein dann schlägt oder so gibt es
da nicht irgendwie beim abendmahl oder
so dass er irgendwie ein irgendwie so
ein zeichen auch sendet habe es ist
falsch
im kopf dass auch jesus irgendwie
gegenüber einem von neunter
also irgendwie also jedenfalls also
wichtiger bezug christologie und
kreuzestheologie und so ganz ganz
prominent ja jetzt hatten sie sich mit
ich glaube wir werden den schönen worden
nein
in dem ganzen dass diese bilder
eigentlich sich so auch wollen durch
diese verteilung vielleicht haben
auch er war das böse gegeben muss zur
folge hatte
vor allem das selbst auch klare mehrheit
tatsächlich gelesen aufgefahren
was ich aber auch sagen dass lernen
gekleidet in dieses design
also
also es ist nicht so ist nicht einfach
sich als erlöser 5er durchschauten
lassen warum passiert er weiß gar nicht
dass er sich dafür
ist wirklich eigentlich
spannend ist
eine schlichte twardy warum nichts
versteht
was sie verstehen von einer seite
nämlich dass für einmal gerne
vergleichen
überhaupt ihr nicht gegangen und da gute
aus- und beschlägt
das ist einfach so verstanden hat
der war eigentlich
schön nett richtig eingestimmt und das
sagt alles in scherben über das zu sagen
muss und die des kurses aufnahmen wir
haben sich viele betriebe zu kommen
halten
deswegen funktionen die eigentlich bis
sie verhandelt der die erzählungen der
moderne aber durch das von 2 konnte ist
in die spitzengruppe auf einen schlag
für mich
die freiheit gestalten
leute die nicht mehr abhängig ist
diese macht spielen
wir sind ja alles gute mehr also sitzen
es ist nicht so dass alles gute
es kommt nix is klar dass ich dachte ist
das böse ist einfach nur dumm sondern
verstehen kannst es selbst zugute
personen die überhaupt nicht versteht
was verspielt ganze ein bisschen ebene
haftet figur ist die weit etwas
grundlegend ein liebes kindliches hat so
wie man kinder ja auch nur mit mühen es
ist wirklich negativ an
fällt es schwer ein kind vor einem bösen
zu verbleiben
als zweiter und sagt das war keine gute
kamera
extrem intensiv vorschuss weil man quasi
das durchschauen ihrer taten uns
zutrauen und ganz ähnlich funktioniert
das müsse damit rechnen kann
als permanenten ausgegeben
diese verzweiflung im leben was ich dann
von selber auf kulturbetrieb und ihre
autoritäre erziehung da sonst keine
echte herzlichkeit seiner und
jedes böse stehen machen
wir müssen uns mit diesem begriff oder
dieser wendung der banalität noch ein
bisschen mehr auseinandersetzen aber
haben jetzt sehr viele wichtige punkte
sie noch und dann gehen wir zum nächsten
zitat über her
im prinzip so gesehen schuldig weil er
verstanden
april den schultern es gleich noch
einmal versteuertes erfüllt aber jetzt
auch schulter was mit schultis und wenn
man so möchte dass er gegen diese
analogie zum kind werden in den kantonen
zürich sein eigen
die geist gemeinde zugestanden wird auf
der anderen seite sich dann aber gegen
das problem dass hier eine
entschuldigung für selbstjustiz lehrer
war ein geben und nehmen dass der
wechsel klappt das nicht will ist dass
das übel irgendwie zu gunsten
[Musik]
da muss man eben dazu sagen dass billy
budd ihrem kleckert nicht töten wollte
er hat ja nicht die absicht ihn zu fall
so zu bringen dass er sich dabei so
schwer verletzen er hat aus einem affekt
heraus mehr oder weniger sich gesträubt
gegen das böse weil seine reaktion die
auch der leser so wahrnehmen würde das
da das gute ebenso gut es auch ist eine
gegenreaktion ausüben muss sie aber
nicht jetzt darauf gerichtet ist dass
das böse in der gestalt klägers jetzt
vernichtet wird sind einfach das gute
sondern mal macht sich bemerkbar
offenbar ist ich glaube nicht dass man
zu sehr jetzt auf die figur billy budd
reflektieren sollte und auf diese tat
weil die nicht der eigentliche grund ist
für seine hinrichtung sind die gründe
hast du glaub ich ziemlich gut
dargestellt
die gründe sind viel komplexer die
gründe sind in der ganzen struktur
dieses schiffes gelegen in dem genau
verstrickung mehr
also ich glaube nicht dass man nur
isoliert jetzt auf diese einzelne aktion
die ihr so ein reflex ist von billy budd
achten sollte von diesen ganzen
verstrickungen ausgehen sollte
das ist ein recht gutes ziel so nach dem
motto das ganze wird natürlich seine tat
die er nicht will nicht gerettet damit
ist die zahl der brände doch irgendwie
auch wenn sie aufgestellt werden
das haben wir ja ich glaube eben dass
man das nicht aus dem kontext der
auslösen darf weil es folgt ja auf diese
affekthandlung noch bestrafung und er
nimmt den tod ja auf sich und ich glaube
davon müssen wir das hier sehen also von
der einwilligung billy budd in die
todesstrafe da dann nicht mehr dagegen
zu opponieren sondern im gegenteil sogar
noch den captain wie heißt der veg
schreibt wie er ist ja dann auch und
gerade nachgeschaut lateinisch virus war
das wahrhaftige dem dann auch noch alles
gute zu wünschen
damit eben das ganze schiff dann weiter
segeln kann dass die welt weiter geht es
schief ist natürlich allegorisch für die
welt die menschheit stehend das ist der
entscheidende punkt nichts ist ja die
effekte - dann glaube ich ihr das in
kauf nehmen des toten
ja genau es muss auch noch recht
eingehalten werden das ist richtig aber
ich glaube eben dass die ganze
hinrichtung nicht bezogen werden solche
auf die effekt handlungen sind auf den
gesamten kontext mit kleckert das eben
da schon eine unruhe gestiftet wurde
und diese unruhe wird letztendlich
dadurch aufgehoben das alles an ihm also
an der figur billy budd aufgehoben wird
erhebt das ganze auf
[Musik]
sie sagen meldet ist kein grund ist eine
tätigkeit wenig interessiert also zum
kriminalfall entstehen
es wird es nicht einfach
mehr
sie tun ist nicht wie es schüttet und
nicht verboten sind jene bei welt
gekommen
über walton ist das alles eher steht er
dem transfer tennis muss
der kosmische geschichte also wenn da so
ein schiff ist in das oval ist dann geht
es gleich ich bedingt war da gibt es im
tierschutz der gegend geht es nicht um
natur entdecken sondern da geht es um
ganz tiefe die germanen ist immer etwas
der kapitän erhält es ist nicht
irgendwie einfach nur ein wildgewordener
rachsüchtiger kapitän dasteht für eine
kosmische street genauso wie alle drei
hatten ihre antwort jetzt ich bin jetzt
hier bei politik hier schon
turniere gehören klasse abend 17 jahre
an alice schwarzer und einen südländer
die stehen dann für unterschiedliche
mentalitäten unterschiedliche triebe
unterschiedliche das leben der welt
weltwelt dimension charaktere als
persönlichkeit
das ist jetzt sind keine die spannen es
sind vordergründig also ist im job
gemacht aber dadurch verbessert der
punkt ja immer sehr sehr sehr
geheimnisvolles will
deswegen sind so fragen verdunkeln ja
wobei die frage geben schon auf den
typus zielte und wenn es eben um einen
typus geht dann im kleckert also kläger
ist eine verkörperung er ist nicht ein
individuum sondern typus er steht eben
für etwas für den typischen schurken
genauso wie jago aus eben bei
shakespeare auch für einen typus stetes
böse und diese typen hat sie jetzt im
hintergrund und vor diesem hintergrund
dieser typologie des bösen möchte sie
jetzt eben mal betrachten sie können
sich schon vorstellen wenn wir jetzt
erhöhen transzendent allis muss und so
weiter diese riesen tiefendimension die
aufladung dieser typen was dann für ein
urteil über eichmann rauskommen was wenn
man ihn jetzt aus spielt gegen diese
charakterstarke figuren regiert sagt sie
weiter schon immer gab es um den
wirklichen übeltäters etwas wie eine
aura von vornehmheit allerdings
selbstverständlich nicht bei den kleinen
halunken die lügen und beim spiel
betrügen
jago und kleckert handeln aus neid auf
diejenigen von denen sie wissen dass sie
besser sind als sie selbst leidet wird
die schlichte und jetzt kommt's
gottgegebene vornehmheit des [ __ ]
hotel oder die sogar noch schlechtere
reinheit und unschuld des unter deck
leichtmatrosen billy budd demgegenüber
kleckert ganz klar gesellschaftlich und
beruflich besser dasteht
die psychologische einsicht von kirche
oder der ihm folgende literatur stelle
ich nicht in frage doch ist nicht
offensichtlich dass es selbst in diesem
leid aus verzweiflung noch immer so
etwas wie vornehmheit gibt unter wir von
der wir wissen dass sie mit der
wirklichen sache äußerst wenig zu tun
hat fragezeichen nach nietzsche
respektiert der mann der sich selbst
verachtet zumindest denjenigen in ihm
der verachtet doch das wirklich böse ist
das was bei uns sprachloses entsetzen
verursacht wenn wir nichts anderes mehr
sagen kann als
dies hätte geschehen dürfen okay wie
charakterisiert sie jetzt das
traditionelle böse das klassische böse
sollte man es vielleicht besser nennen
anhand dieser typen aus den besagten
durch man erkennt hier gleich hand ist
eine bildungs bürgerinnen das muss man
gleich sagen dass sie hält davor nicht
zurück sie zeigt was sie alles gelesen
hat
das ist von den 50ern so bis in die 50er
60er kam das total gut an
dann gab es glaube ich so ein bruch
macht man heute nicht mehr so heute ist
man da so ein bisschen zurückhaltender
scheint mir jetzt gerade aber ist ein
anderes thema wie charakterisiert sie
denn jetzt noch einmal diesen
klassischen typus des bösen den sie in
der literatur verkörpert sieht was hatte
er was ein anderer nämlich man nicht hat
das eigen nennt sie jetzt noch nicht
aber das wird der grund wird
ja und haben sie da zum beispiel einen
bezug jetzt direkt im zitat gleich am
anfang es gibt sie ein stichwort was
eben auf diesen typus des klassisch
bösen zutreffen würde genau genau hier
ganz genau
ja ja ja und also hier geht wo diese
motive die schlichte reinheit und
unschuld
wie die vornehmheit
und sie würde jetzt sagen sie das
wirklich böse das beschreibt sie noch
nicht sie spielt jetzt hier von dem
wirklich bösen
das dürfte dann wenn ich es recht
verstehe keine vornehmheit mehr haben
sondern das würde sprachloses entsetzen
verursachen und eben dieses diesen satz
von uns provozieren was mir jetzt noch
aufgefallen ist was ich noch nicht so
gesehen habe ist es die betrachtet jetzt
das böse dieses wirklicher böse von der
wirkung her und nicht von der
verfasstheit des bösen selbst also wie
mir scheint kann man das wirklich böse
nach hannah arendt nur noch wirkungs
geschichtlich wirkungs ästhetische
wirkung psychologisch erfassen nämlich
dass es uns sprachloses entsetzen
verursacht heißt und es verschlägt ist
die sprache wir können nur noch das
sagen dies hätte nicht geschehen dürfen
das ist so ein zug bei der bestimmung
des bösen der mir relativ neu zu sein
scheint da könnte hannah arendt die
erste eine der ersten sein die diesen
zug betonen susan nehmen kennen sie aber
schreibt sie nehmen zu nehmen hat ein
buch geschrieben
was vor zehn jahren erschien ist das
heißt das böse denken und darin vertritt
sie diese these oder die ich jetzt eben
gerade formuliert habe dass wir über das
böse nur noch sprechen sollten jetzt
kurz gesagt von der wirkung seite des
opfers her
sie hat eine ganz starke opfer
zentrierte sich und ich bin ein bisschen
skeptisch dass wir uns so den bösen
nähern sollten nur vom opfer her aber
ich gebe ihr recht zumindest dass das
böse immer komplementär betrachtet
werden muss von der täterseite von der
motivlage her und von der rezessions
lage her jetzt mal in anführungsstrichen
vom opfer her glaube das böse muslimas
täter und opfer behandelt ich persönlich
würde aber aus gewissen gründen der
täterperspektive dennoch den vorzug
geben weil wir immer fragen warum warum
kam es dazu
hier jedenfalls scheint sie fast schon
zu unterstellen dass man dieses warum
bei dem wirklich bösen gar nicht mehr
stellen kann diese frage das scheint das
zentrale zu zahlen jetzt ziehen sie ja
dasselbe tragen dass diese leistung sagt
dass jeder verein lösen dass das jetzt
in der
und sich dann irgendwie männer
unterwäsche trotzdem neben der würdigung
anderen wirklich das böse als er nämlich
über sich ergehen lässt das scheint es
um unterschiedliche studien reihen wir
müssen zugeben was einfach dieses das
böse an sich ist ohne zwischen dem was
man sich auszuruhen und man kann sich
völlig den bösen geben und dann wie
später weil es einfach gegen bösen
handelt also wieder ein system was es
vorgibt und somit alle verantwortung was
sie von sich zu weisen sicher dass
selbst entdecken oder momentan gegen
böse die hälfte nun etwas zu erreichen
wie aber ist nicht böse sein ich denke
es geht in diese richtung das also
dieses automatische dass das eben gerade
sprachloses entsetzen verursacht weil es
eben nicht mehr dieses vornehmen hat es
hat keine aura mehr
es ist das total mechanische böse wie
sie gesagt hat ich glaube das trifft
sehr gut es ist das totale and
personalisierte nd charakterisierte and
typisierte aufgelöste böse was einfach
nur noch in funktionieren besteht ist
das funktionierende böse könnte man
sagen da gibt es keine persönlichkeit
mehr
da gibt es niemand der sich selbst auch
verachten könnte dann sondern gibt es
halt nur noch den mechanismus
letztendlich ne
ja
ja ja richtig
oder
ich gebe einfach
und wie
naja ich denke dafür dahin geht es in
diese richtung wo auch eben so was wie
psychologische ansichten von der sie
hierbei kirchenchor spricht nichts mehr
bringt die psychologische einsicht da
gibt es keine richtigen motive mir keine
psychologie des bösen oder noch genauer
die rezeption des bösen die rezeption
des bösen man könnte nur noch eine
geschichte schreiben guter punkt wie das
böse gewirkt hat also nur noch die die
rezeption die wahrnehmung des bösen das
hat das und uns selbst das könnte man
nicht mehr schreiben weil sie ein
sprachloses entsetzen ist kann das gar
nicht mehr schreiben ist sprachlos
so könnte man es jedenfalls jetzt mal
und apportieren sie sehen wir greifen
hier sehr viel voraus ja war noch eine
meldung habe ich noch jemanden übersehen
der sich melden wollte wir greifen jetzt
sehr viel voraus und müssen jetzt das
ganze konkretisieren wir antizipieren
gerade noch sehr viel was dann mit
eichmann zu tun hatten jetzt kommt die
philosophie und auch wie ich zuvor
bemerkt hatte die große literatur da
sagt die bildungs bürgerin arendt
natürlich kennt den schurken nur als
jemanden der verzweifelt ist von dessen
verzweiflung
das haben wir schon mit einem gewissen
adlung gibt ich will nicht leugnen dass
dieser typ des übeltäters existiert bin
aber sicher dass die größten über die
wir kennen und das war das was hier
gesagt hat dass will
wirklich böse wie das wirklich böse und
jetzt im nächsten zitat spricht sie von
dem größten übel die wir kennen ihn
nicht ihm zuzuschreiben sind der sich
wieder in die augen sehen müssen dessen
fluches ist dass er nicht vergessen kann
die größen im bild das sind jede die
sich nicht erinnern weil sie auf das
getan niemals gedanken verschwendet
haben und ohne erinnerung kann nicht sie
zurückhaltend
das denken an vergangene angelegenheiten
bedeutet für menschliche wesen sich in
die dimension der tiefe zu begeben
wurzeln zu schlagen und so sich selbst
zu stabilisieren so dass man nicht bei
allem möglichen dem zeitgeist geschichte
da einfach der versuchung hin
weggeschwemmte das größte böse ist nicht
radikal es hat keine wurzeln weil es
keine wurzeln hat hat es keine grenzen
kann sich ins unvorstellbare extrem
entwickeln und über die ganze welt
ausbreiten das ist eine ganz bekannte
passage wie geht's jetzt natürlich
wieder sehr um metaphern muss hier immer
profitieren auf die verwendete
metaphorik es geht um wurzeln ja wie
kann man jetzt diese wurzel metapher
auch tiefe tiefe ist eine metapher dann
sagt das war ein tiefer gedanke es ist
eine metapher alle alles metaphern wie
kann man diese metaphern jetzt hier
auflösen wurzeln schlagen wie kann man
die jetzt hier auflösen bezüglich dieser
theorie des wirklich bösen oder des
größten überziehen
zu seinen kunden
ja aber die frau jetzt haben sie wieder
die metapher verwendet wurzeln aber was
ist denn die wurzeln
das wäre zwar hat die auf eine mögliche
auflösung der wurzel genau also eine
wurzel ist ein grund grund ist wieder
eine metapher grund der grund dürfte
boden also das fundament oder die
motivlage ich weiß nicht ob jemand von
ihnen hier noch in meinem seminar war
doch eine und kommilitonen ist
jedenfalls im seminar über die
begeistert ihre und da habe ich einen
text von doppel davidson gelesen und
haben wir zusammen gelesen und donner
davidson amerikanischer philosoph sagt
ein gedanken zu haben eine position zu
haben eine professionelle einstellung
dass etwas der fall ist weist darauf hin
dass weitere gedanken vorhanden sind man
kann nie nur einen einzelnen gedanken
haben wenn man einen gedanken hat hat
man immer mehrere gedanken gedanken
kommt immer in einem netz einen
holistischen gefühl bevor einzelne
gedanken gibt es nicht sagt davidson
ich glaube dass man es auch so sehen
kann also hier die tiefe die wurzeln das
heißt das böse das traditionelle böse
das wurzel hafte böse ist ein netz von
gründen von motiven ja dass letztendlich
die ganze die konkrete handlung fundiert
die handlung wieder wie die spitze des
eisbergs ist die handlung die böse
handlung und der ganze eisberg
eisklumpen unter wasser der ist die
wurzel der ist diese motiv das motiv
arsenal was sich angestaut hat so könnte
man es vielleicht sagen
dass sie das nicht unfassbar was gegen
diese intention von bundes und direkt
auf eine lehrstelle
also das ist doch
jetzt das ist eigentlich das problem was
machen was die mitgliedschaft ihres
richtig ich glaube dass es richtig ist
und wie verstehen sie jetzt hier diese
wendung hebt wenn es keine wurzeln oder
weil es keine wurzeln hat hat das keine
grenzen kann sich ins unvorstellbare
extrem entwickeln und über die ganze
welt ausbreite haben sie eine andere
metapher an anderen vergleich der diese
charakteristik des bösen dieses wirklich
lösen dient das jetzt von den
traditionellen klassischen bösen
abgrenzt verständlich machen
lösen indem das böse eben wir haben
bestimmte dienstag bestellte an den fan
shirt ist einfach ein mensch mit diesen
eigenschaften sein und aus diesen
eigenschaften muss ein die wolken
beiseite
sie wollen so werden diese erst mal
nicht mehr normal und auch ihnen da
nicht mehr lokal streitbar aber ließen
sie dann zum beispiel böse sein dass
gegenüber stehen wieder zwei sozialismus
ja das ist finde ich ein guter vorschlag
sie wenn ich sie recht verstanden habe
würde sie sagen das wirklich böse ist
letztendlich eine kalkulation also eine
eine struktur in dem man etwas einsetzt
ist diese person jetzt in diesem fall
jüdisch und wenn das der fall ist dann
folgt das so könnte man sich vorstellen
also dass man sagt das böse ist ala ist
ein algorithmus egoismus biologische
funktion die auf einer ideologie
natürlich fust eine rassenideologie die
natürlich an sich höchst problematisch
ist aber wenn man die eben jetzt glaubt
diese ideologie dann würde das ganze
daraus folgen und dann wäre das nicht
mehr jetzt an einzelnen personen
festzumachen sind es wäre halt die logik
oder die ideologie die das eben vorgibt
das wäre eine möglichkeit und so eine
ideologie könnte sich eben ganz schnell
weil sie eben so suggestiv ist und weil
sie nicht gebunden ist an bestimmte
individuen könnte die sich wie so eine
krankheit wie es eine ansteckende
krankheit ganz schnell ausbreiten ist
eine ideologie die steckt alle an bis
ein flächenbrand
das sage ich das aber nicht und sie
baten die politiker wolle damit war nun
was ist was wäre gewesen wenn
hätte die ganze fabrik habe auch sagen
würdest du selbst gewesen wäre
der erde ist schlicht ja ich denke also
dass das durchaus in die richtige
richtung geht das sagen man fokussiert
hier nicht mehr auf die persönlichen
motive sondern einfach nur noch auf
vorschriften auf vorschriften auf
algorithmen die eben weil sie so
abstrakt und so formal sind nicht nur
diese tiefe brauchen sind überall
angewendet werden können über
institutionalisiert werden können
wir
wir kommen hier
trotzdem
dasselbe stellen
entsprechende was hat in schweden mehr
als noch nicht mehr ein
wir versuchen ja auch zu schade
dahinter folgen
guter punkt die frage ist eben die
natürlich kann man fragen woher kommt
ideologie die ideologie wurde im
nationalsozialismus natürlich von
bestimmten personen hoch gehalten aber
zum beispiel die ideologie des rassismus
oder auch die ideologie des kommunismus
die oder die radikalen problematischen
ideologien die werden heute vertreten
unabhängig davon dass man sich fragen ob
von dem kommt jetzt das einfach ein
gedanke der setzt sich fest in unserem
kopf und der wirkt total überzeugend ist
das ist ein ganz einfacher
erklärungsansatz der erklärt die die
diversität der welt die unüberschaubare
moderne erklärt dem mit wenigen sätzen
und plötzlich wissen wir wo es langgeht
genau immer durch
[Musik]
ja ja ich glaube aber dass mit wurzel
hier ihr jetzt der täter gemeint ist der
dingfest gemacht werden kann und das
kann ich bei einer ideologie nicht eine
ideologie lässt sich nicht individuell
ihren es gibt nicht die ideologie hier
läuft sie hier liegt die ideologie hier
ist das buch wurde ideologie dargelegt
ist okay aber dann gibt es gibt es
diesen text im internet und dann gibt es
den text als digitale datei im internet
und kann ich nichts mehr
individualisieren dann legt er auf einem
server und dann ist er dupliziert
gespeichert kann down geläutet werden
und vervielfältigt werden ich glaube so
man sich das vorstellen
es gibt niemanden der jetzt diese
ideologie verbirgt im
nationalsozialismus gab es einige
personen die die verfügt haben habe ich
glaube selbst wenn diese person nicht
mehr gelebt hätten oder ermordet worden
wären hätte die ideologie weitergelebt
genau so wie es ja mit rassismus mit
kommunismus und so weiter ist die ist
nicht gebunden an bestimmte personen die
die wahrheit verbirgt sondern sie hat
eine eigendynamik und ich glaube dass
das damit gemeint ist eine eigendynamik
die eben nicht mehr individualisierbar
ist sondern eine form bezeichnet die
gewisse weise abstraktes aber sich
deswegen über alles legen kann also die
form praktisch des bösen
das ist nicht einfach zu halten oder um
alles geht es ein wenig sind da im fort
es ist eine einsetzung in ein schema
eine ideologie ich setze etwas ein
ist das der fall oder nicht ich
entscheide macht eine falle entscheidung
und wenn diese fall entscheidung
getroffen ist dann gibt die ideologie
vor dem mechanismus der theologie was zu
tun ist
das sagt nicht nur eine bestimmte person
sind es sagt halt die ideologie die
ideologie verlangt das von mir
durchaus es muss nicht unbedingt nur ein
ideologien geknüpft sein
das kann sie muss etwas sein was sich
verselbstständigt was sich
verselbstständigt und es war so für
selbstständig dass es nicht mehr an
bestimmte personen oder täter der
klassischen literatur angebunden werden
kann
[Applaus]
genau das sagt sie ist das grenzenlose
keine wurzeln mehr würde diesmal weiter
das böse wenn hinsichtlich das selbst
und des denkenden austausches zwischen
mir und mir selbst bestimmt bleibt so
formal da haben wir die form so
inhaltsleer wie kants kategorischer
imperativ
dessen formalismus seine kritiker so oft
in rage versetzt hat wenn kann sagte
jede maximal die kerne universal
gültiges gesetz werden kann ist unrecht
so ist das als hätte sokrates gesagt
jede tat sei unrecht mit deren urheber
ich nicht mehr zusammenleben können
der vergleich scheint ganz aussage
weniger formal und sehr viel strenger zu
sein die pst und mord fälschungen
falsches zeugnis ablegen werden gleicher
härte untersagen die frage ob ich nicht
lieber mit einem dieb als mit einem
mörder sein leben möchte ob ich
vielleicht ein fälscher beträchtlich
weniger gern hätte als jemand der eine
falsche zeugenaussage gemacht hat wird
nicht einmal gestellt also hier geht es
jetzt ein bisschen um die kritik an kant
theorie die können wir aber eigentlich
ein bisschen überspringen weil
weil sie wirft das vielleicht noch der
grund für diese unterstützen unterschied
liegt auch darin dass kann trotz
gegenteiliger beteuerung eben doch nicht
genau zwischen legalität und moralität
trennte und der moralität ohne
vermittlungen zur quelle des gesetzes
machen wollte so dass der mensch wo
immer er hinging und was immer er tat
sein eigener gesetzgeber eine völlig
autonome person war in kans aussage ist
das böse dasselbe ob es die menschen zum
lied oder zum mörder marken es handelt
sich um die gleiche unheilvoll schwächen
der menschennatur ein weiteres und
selbstverständlich sehr gewichtiges
beispiel dafür dass übertretungen
aufgelistet und nicht entspricht ihre
schwere bestraft werden ist der dekalog
verdienen auch angenommen wurde dass er
die grundlage der im land geltenden
rechtsordnung gewesen ist also wird kann
ich mir im einzelnen zu unterscheiden
und jetzt kommt ein wichtiger als zitat
was uns wieder zurück bringt zwei
unserer eigentlichen frage sagt das
lässt sich an den nazi verbrechen war
gerade dass sie will endlich auf alle
persönlichen eigenschaften verzichteten
als ob dann niemand mehr übrig bliebe
der entweder bestraft oder dem vergeben
werden könnte jemand immer wieder
beteuerten sie niemals etwas aus
eigeninitiative getan zu haben sie
hatten keine wie auch immer gearteten
guten oder bösen ansichten gehabt und
immer nur befehle befolgen
ja
ich glaube daher dass jetzt ziemlich
deutlich jetzt vor augen
diese darstellung der nazi verbrecher
wie sie sagt verglichen mit den
klassischen vornehmen helden der
literatur also bösewichte die durchaus
einen helden charakter haben teilweise
also die die etwas bewunderung
provozieren wenn wir sie betrachten so
was sagt sie gibt zwar die nazi fabrik
nicht wir könnten da eben die gar nicht
mehr richtig dingfest machen
es hätten nur befehle befolgt und hier
diesen nur befehle befolgen gar nicht zu
dieser mechanismus drehen den sie auch
dargestellt haben diese form diese
ideologie ich es geht gar nicht mehr um
mich jetzt als akteur als individuum
benutzt dann der betrachtung um das böse
geht sondern hier wurde einfach nur ein
befehl befolgt der befehl der wurde
abgeleitet aus irgendeiner ordnung aus
einem prinzip das aber nicht mehr jetzt
konkret dingfest zu machen ist
ja genau genau
genau also nicht nicht ohne zufall
nicht zufällig kommt dann in dieser zeit
auch so 60er 70er von foucault der tod
des objekts und so diese ganzen tod
erklärung des objekts des individuums in
einer gesellschaft die nicht mehr
überschaubare nicht eine ideologie ist
eine antwort und lösungsangebot auf die
überschaubarkeit der welt technologie
treten da auf wo die welt zu schwierig
wird um sie zu verstehen die stände
ordnung wird aufgegeben
es gibt extreme aufstiegsmöglichkeiten
es gibt weltwirtschaftskrisen die
menschen die reich war müssen wieder von
vorne beginnen und so weiter es wird
nicht nur übersichtlich und in der
moderne kommt die ideologie und sie
ersetzt das subjekt
überhaupt das erste mal probiert mit auf
aber nicht viel trainieren und das ist
eine entscheidung
ohnehin verwerfen und machen sie gestern
verstehen
und das interesse
ja
und sagen
unsere bestätigung noch sowas von
überhaupt
entscheiden sie uns auch
januar beim 1
leben das ist glaube ich der punkt also
es nach dieser modernen diagnose geht es
nicht nur um das objekt individuen
sondern es geht um jakob es geht um wie
gesagt dies positiv es geht um
formationen von co spricht von
formationen in ordnung die ordnung des
diskurses ja wer ist die ordnung
jedenfalls kein subjekt gut wir reden
von der ordnung wie ein subjekt aber es
ist keine person die ihr ding für smart
das sind diese mechanismen die uns in
kneipen anderes beispiel literatur ist
kafka franz kafka das schloss der
prozess gemacht in dem prozess völlig
unklar
das schloss wer ist wer ist die leitung
des schlosses anonym die anonymität der
gesellschaft die nicht mehr dingfest zu
machen ich glaube dass das hier alles so
mit reinspielt und diese moderne theorie
des bösen wenn es in eine theorie
überhaupt ist bei hannah arendt weiter
verständlich werden lässt ja
14 zusammenpassen
die dame von der politik
die eigenen
das erste mini dass wir eben keine
drähte kein problem haben können sie
auch gesagt
das ist niemand mehr helfen werde
dazu haben wir das größte und einzige
komplett danach handelt und aufnahmen
zeigen erste aber gegen so es gibt ja
immer einfach
tatsächlich
die tat doch das ist eben die tt jemand
muss die tat wirklich gebraucht werden
ist es ist besteht immer noch diese
entscheidung zur möglichkeit ja oder
nein
richtig wobei man dann eben immer sagen
könnte da konnte
aber wenn sie es nicht getan hätten wenn
sie sich dem befehl verweigert hätten
wenn sie den gehorsam verweigert hätten
dann hätten sie wiederum was zu
befürchten gehabt dass alles läuft
darauf hinaus dass die schuld immer
weiter delegiert wird wenn ich es nicht
gemacht hätte dann hätte das gemacht und
dann hätte ich die strafe bekommen
das ist die strategie jedenfalls die
sich diese subjekte zurecht legen die
dann eben ihre ganz subjektivität
delegieren ich gebe alles meint sie ich
gebe meine verantwortung ab ich
delegiere sie alleine ideologie an einem
mac imaginäre fixpunkt des führers des
staates und so weiter und so fort
ja richtig
und da hat man eben durchaus auch zu
recht kanaren so ein bisschen ein
vorwurf gemacht dass sie da alles
versucht hat dann zu entschuldigen die
frage ist überhaupt die wie steht es mit
der schuld sind solche leute die eben
jetzt auf diese ganzen punkte verzichten
oder sich nur auf befehle berufen
ist das wirklich ein entschuldigungs
grund oder was mir sehr sympathisch ist
diese lesart dass man sagt und das ist
ein bisschen gegen hannah arendt jetzt
gegen strich ihre argumentation dass man
sagt naja gut eben um es um seine ganze
persönlichkeit aufzugeben um sich selbst
zu bloßer befehlsempfänger zu machen
muss sich ja eine entscheidung treffen
also ich muß ein selbstbild entwickeln
ein selbstbild dass ich kein selbst mehr
bin aber dass ich kann selbst mehr sein
möchte dass ich meine individualität
aufgebe das ist ein individueller
akdemir zuzurechnen ist also darin sehe
ich eher so ein einfallstor für kritiker
sind als subjekte die aufgehört haben
objekte zu sein
aber und das gegen arendt jetzt das
nicht einfach so und sie haben sich
bewusst dagegen dafür entschieden keines
objekte mensch sein zu wollen
oder
ja ja
könnte man sagen oder es muss nicht
grund oder es muss eben eine maxime
gewesen sein wie bei kant eine
grundsatzentscheidung aber die wird
nicht von heute auf morgen gefällt sind
seine maxime wird abgewogen und man kann
auch gründe dafür geben warum man das
jetzt gemacht hat als das wäre so ein
bisschen sondern so ein punkt gegen alle
haben
ja
ja schon aber wenn man wenn man jetzt
eben dann diese rechtfertigung betrieben
hat ich war es nicht es war ja die
umstände da wird man dann plötzlich
wieder als objekt aktiv indem man gründe
anführt und letztendlich sich
rechtfertigt und im rechtfertigen glaube
ich schon dass hier das hier wieder eine
person zum vorschein kommt die sich als
moralisches objekt auch eignen würde sie
in dem man eben sagt warum man kein
subjekt ist zeigt man eben wieder gerade
dass man zurückliegt ist die gründe
dafür anzugeben für seine subjekt los
losigkeit dieses zu motivieren das ist
gerade wieder subjektiv und ist wieder
also subjektiv in dem sind greifbar dass
es wieder vorwirft
gar nicht möglich
wir legen diese
die bilanz solcher an bord ist es
eigentlich niemals an futter als
unwissend gelten hat überhaupt fielen
fast ins freibad zu entwickeln
das hin gesagt es könnte möglich landet
seine person die komplette bin zwar
haben sie selbst arbeitet
genau dazu passt noch dieses letzte
zitat weil wir zeitlich jetzt schon
recht fortgeschritten sind letztes zitat
was es auch nochmal glaube ich gut auf
den punkt bringen um es anders zu sagen
das größte begann nervös ist das böse
das von niemandem getan wurde das heißt
von menschlichen wesen die sich weigern
personen das in konzeptionellen rahmen
dieser betrachtungen könnten wir
feststellen dass übeltäter die sich
weigern selbst darüber nachzudenken was
sie tun und die sich auch im nachhinein
gegen das denken wären also sich weigern
zurück zu gehen und sich an das zu
ändern was sie taten wobei es sich um
der schufa oder handelt es eigentlich
versäumt haben sich als ein jemand zu
konstituieren indem sie sturköpfe kann
niemand bleiben erweisen sie sich als
unfähig mit anderen zu kommunizieren die
ob nun gut böse oder in dieser hinsicht
unbestimmter zumindest aber personen
sind als er hier wichtiger punkt noch
dass sich entziehen einer kommunikations
gemeinschaft das fand auch ganz wichtig
also das gute hat etwas mit verweigerung
von dialog zu tun
aus dieser kommunikationssituation
auszusteigen
na und
genau
genau sie haben es versäumt sich als
jemand konstituieren und ich glaube auch
dass sie es versäumt haben den anderen
als jemand zu konstituieren durch
empathie oder kommunikation das heißt
man hat es nur noch mit objekten zu tun
ich objekt funktionär oder bloß
empfiehlt empfänger und objekt als opfer
auch nur objekt das ist sie eine welt
der objekte sozusagen
ja er ist als auch nicht
ja dazu noch ein letzter punkt diese
theorie wenn es eine theorie denn ist
von hannah arendt ist in jüngster zeit
sehr in kritik geraten bei einer
philosophie die heißt bettina stangneth
die hat ein buch geschrieben mit dem
titel eichmann vor jerusalem also vor
dem prozess in jerusalem eine art hat er
diese bemerkung anlässlich des prozesses
mit eichmann in jerusalem formuliert und
bettina stand hat herausgefunden dass
eichmann wohl vor jerusalem bevor
geschnappt wurde sich sehr auf seine
rolle vorbereitet hat also ehrlich man
habe ganz bewusst diese rolle da
stilisiert als es sich als ein bloßes
empfiehlt empfänger fingiert und das
würde wieder dafür sprechen dass da eben
durchaus ein subjekt dahinter war dass
eben nur so getan hat sich getarnt hat
als bloßes als bloßer befehlsempfänger
dabei wie immer noch subjekt geblieben
ist und diesen aspekt sich bei hannah
arendt bisschen zu wenig beleuchtet also
sie waren vielleicht ein bisschen naiv
könnte man sagen dass sie es nicht für
möglich gehalten hat dass jemand so gut
schauspielert wäre möglich zumindest
bettina stangneth dass er die ganze das
ganze gerichte hinters licht führen
wollte und nur so tat als sei völlig
banal dabei war erreicht man mit einer
stange versucht hat zu zeigen durchaus
eine persönlichkeit die eben in diesen
situationen sich so dargestellt hat als
ich keinen letzter punkt noch hier
[Musik]
si
genau richtig ich gebe ihnen recht also
eine art mag sich vielleicht im falle
von eichmann gehört haben ich denke aber
dennoch das ist dass sie einen wichtigen
punkt getroffen hat dass selbst wenn man
jetzt nicht banal war sicherlich nicht
war aber selbst wenn das nicht der fall
gewesen sein sollte ist die theorie
extrem wichtig wenn es eine theorie ist
weil sie wirklich versucht dieses große
funktionieren die sich für objektivieren
und das in anderen für objektive
wirklich meins bewusstsein gerufen hat
und durchaus abgegrenzt hat von diesen
klassischen bösewichtern weil solche
klassische bösewichter sind natürlich
nicht mehr denkt ist ein guter punkt ja
dann sind wir am ende der heutigen
sitzung und auch am ende des seminars
als ganzen heer schützt und ich hatte es
großen spaß gemacht wir haben hier
wirklich einen gewaltigen schritt
unternommen von den anfängen des bösen
vom sündenfall bis zu etwas bösem was
wie hannah arendt gar nicht mehr
greifbar ist die ablösung des bösen
vielleicht wie auch immer wir sind jetzt
also fast eine gegenwart ja mit bettina
stangneth buch sind in der gegenwart
wirklich angekommen
wir haben die zusammenfassung
herumgeschickt sie haben alle gesammelt
bekommen
wir bieten wir noch ein paar
sprechstunden an wenn sie sich wenn sie
eine hausarbeit schreiben wollen
schreiben sie bitten uns beide
kontaktieren uns beide und dann können
wir mal termin vereinbaren und gemeinsam
ein solches thema besprechen dann
wünschen wir beide ihnen noch eine
schöne vorlesungsfreie zeit und
vielleicht sieht man sich ja wieder im
nächsten semester